[موسيقى]
لا نهاية لدمائنا حتى الموت
ما هو الله في حياتنا حتى قطرة؟
دعه يأخذها حتى يكون مفقودًا من رؤوسنا
اذن لا
في سياسة حكومة أردوغان المرأة
لا يوجد مكان تقيم فيه المرأة في المنزل وتعتني بالأطفال
شخص يحتاج إليه
أنا امرأة تركية لتغيير هذه
أريده أن يتغير إلى وإلا
وإلا فسيكون لنا مستقبل سيء للغاية.
هناك نساء قُتلن منتظرات
تقريبا لا شيء من هؤلاء
ومع ذلك ، هؤلاء الناس
لا ينبغي لهم حتى الخروج من السجن
وفق
آمل أن يكون Kılıçdaroğlu
لدعم مستقبلك وأنا أؤيده
سوف أكمل
سمعته مرة أخرى اليوم أنا آسف للغاية
فقدت وزني 450 ليرة انظري انا متقاعد
لكن لا بد لي من العمل على حد سواء 67 70
انا عجوز كيف ستكون هذه الاشياء؟
ان شاء الله
55-60-70٪ يقولون أنها ستذهب إلى الأرض
أعتقد أن رجب طيب أردوغان نفسه
أنا أحب هذا البلد لهذا البلد
أكثر ما يمكن أن يفعله هذا الرجل هو جاحد جدا
للأسف لدينا أناس
[موسيقى]